welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience we've upgraded it to
experience today how can I compete with
Joe Rogan if I'm not an experiment come
on you got to sniff it up here we are
sponsored today by me undies hems and
clip and I am very honored and happy to
introduce the very funny Tom Seguros
here with us today what was that Dan oh
I can hear you through this bomb we have
this notorious problem because now we're
live on YouTube and we can't take
anything back oh right so as long as we
stick the landing yeah it's all good but
I was like I heard and I thought he was
like take it from the top
back to one nothing will okay our we're
stuck
well let me finish my intro Tom Segura
has three extremely funny stand-up
specials on Netflix disgraceful which I
have to say is probably one of my top 5
favorites wow thanks man that's very
nice loving that thank you recommend
everybody check that out thank you
mostly stories and completely normal
they're all on Netflix he's the host of
your mom's and podcasts along with his
wife house oh my god mom's house podcast
I'm zipping right all right we can't
start over again along with his wife
which we have in common
yes christina pazsitzky pretty close
pretty good it's pretty good it's
actually pazsitzky plus she has a as
publicly changed it to christina p thank
you say have you got the public service
yeah you know i was i listen to the
intro of your guys's podcast like 20
times oh really i hate oh names wrong
yeah no you gave a valiant effort but i
wasn't trying to say like hey [ __ ]
yeah he's also going on a tour across
the u.s. starting in august you can buy
tickets at Tom Segura calm slash tour
thank you sir
and very pleased in order to have you
with us thank you thank you guys for
having me here thank you so much thank
you man
I'm a big fan of you guys how's it going
it's going good man not going good
things seem to be going really well for
you seeing you like more and more yeah
and it seems like things are happening
for Tom Segura if
it's been a it's been a good couple
years like with you know it's like
steady things moving along just happy to
be you know doing what I do yeah and
yeah the podcast is is is going along
and the touring has been has been great
so nice I feel very lucky you guys
Netflix started giving getting into
comedy was that a lot like a big
game-changer for you and other comedians
all for sure Ben cuz me when they pay
more you get more I got in what is
considered we're talking about how you
know Internet years are different than
real years yeah so that first one I did
completely normal I did I shot it in
2013 and getting on Netflix was like a
consolation prize hmm that's what like
people now can't even imagine that but
that was the goal was Comedy Central and
Comedy Central was that that was we shot
it in 2013 so five short years yeah and
when they when we shot it and try to
sell out something they were like and
there's not really a theme to it that
was their note yeah we were like I mean
his jokes that's the theme is I'm doing
stand-up the whole time and they were
like critical then I was kind of bummed
out about that you know that that it was
not going to because that was like the
place to be and then I know that I know
was sent to Showtime I remember it must
have been a pass and I don't remember
any note or anything and then I remember
getting the call they're like Netflix is
willing naked they're willing yeah like
they'll do it I'll do that favor and I
was like hmm and they go now it's great
like people watch it all the time you
know cuz it was still like I mean that's
only five years ago but I think that
streaming was still on an upswing people
are still getting DVDs in the mail from
them really oh yeah for sure I mean I
feel like 2012 I remember where I was
living and for sure we were doing DVDs
all the time Wow 2013 probably it's it's
hard to really grasp how much change in
five years I know in technology you know
that's light yeah it's just it's crazy
right it's it's it's so many years right
but then when it went up I didn't know
I remember doing clubs so I shot in 2013
they started streaming in early 2014 and
a few months after that like I sold out
of club one time and this guy was like I
remember the club manager goes I don't
know what the [ __ ] you did but a lot of
people came this week and I was so not
thinking of the effect of this special I
was like I don't know because like
months since I shot it and I was like I
don't know what people are here yeah and
then it just was like a slow and steady
increase from there so having the
exposure because Netflix now has like
half of every household in America it's
crazy now and actually have to say they
promote your for whatever I don't know
I've seen your disgraceful your new
stand-up on the home page almost every
time I so probably because they have you
know it's really a data company and they
study you so much and you should see
when you go a marketing meeting about
something you have coming out the way
that they market you differently in
every territory Wow
different colors different patents I'll
show you on the in your last special
more people clicked on this in Brazil
get all this data well they don't know
they don't provide Italy's give you an
example watch your no I
damn no they don't they don't give me
that [ __ ] interesting of course of
course I think this is great I think
you're you're downplaying yourself a
little bit because it's on trending now
when like popular on Netflix is is oh
really for a long time like in the top
five
oh that's really cool yeah it's been
it's been a fun ride with them for sure
I mean every you know from that time
2013 like which we said was not that
long ago to like now we're now they're
they're more even more selective and
shut people down and no and but and then
give into buying offers that's like 30
million he got 20 million per person for
I love how he balanced and then he came
back and he's like alright I'm
collecting all the money you [ __ ] out
man yeah and then sorry I forgot a
nine-figure deal he does any money so
yeah wait wait for their community wait
nine figures yeah yeah give yourself a
minute though wait for comedians hang up
really well Stefan is a Millie it's okay
hundred yeah under
Plus what so he's you don't need any
more money it's for comedians in cars
getting coffee I think he's gonna do the
special that came out last year another
special right and then another some type
of another original they bought it so
gramming yeah they gotta give us a bunch
of [ __ ] bye Ellen Ellen just got I think
50 she's doing a special I think
producing something else for them
I got like 250 million I was like whoa I
made less than those guys paying
Commission I mean they but they how did
they pay you like compared to what
you're doing before Oh
I mean look it's it's it's like for sure
I mean it's not like it's good it's not
that kind of it's not that kind of money
it's not even in the stratosphere
million isn't like aging that's just
like no even do with them I know I put
like you know the Seinfeld and those
guys money it's crazy yeah it's crazy um
yeah it's nothing like that and by the
way nor should it be like those guys are
it's not just like they're they're just
they're not just they're so famous but
that their origins like I you know some
people who get into the battle of like
what rate somebody gets like dude
they're bringing eyeballs their mother
for buying they're simply monopolizing
all these Titans yes nobody has any
other reason in 30 20 years maybe even
people are just gonna say hey it's and
people are gonna forget the cable and
television was a thing they'll be like
hey put on netflix yeah it's a it's from
an analytical standpoint it really is
interesting to see where will things go
you know we've had guests who are like
oh wow
why you play the whole show no no I see
but no just to see where it'll go
because you kind of go like you know no
one can compete with this with this
model of like paying this kind of money
right and then you know the platform you
know how many eyeballs are already there
it's like what what will happen at least
from stand-up standpoint you go I mean
is are the other competitors gonna do
something or just go that's what I'm
saying
behind on it yeah they're really behind
like from the viewer perspective nothing
can compete with it
okay I can see all the specials I don't
even have to go to a live show if I
can't you know it's you out there it's
all you put it whenever you want there's
no ads it's like yeah who can compete I
know and it's not that expensive it's
not what happened have 150 million
[ __ ] subscribe giving them whatever
like 15 bucks a month and yeah it's a
lot of money man although they're like
spending all of it yeah yeah you know
crazy debt their their growth has been
unbelievable Warren Buffett I think was
Warren Buffett recently said he's like I
cannot buy enough Netflix or maybe sit
about Apple and I'm completely off-base
can you guys research that for me thank
you sure yeah there was one joke from
disgraceful yet I loved yeah and there's
a whole story around it which I loved
even more yeah the one bit that you had
that was so funny
was the one about how you can't say
[ __ ] that's gay or [ __ ] anymore
uh-huh which is such a great bit because
we're actually are we're similar in age
I'm 32
like you're 39 right yeah you're much
younger we come well we come from a
world where we probably both were just
saying [ __ ] like that
I'm bombarded with it hearing it all
exactly that was just you know and and
and the world changed around us in a way
problem you know like happens every
generation sure but it's like they took
yeah that's what look hey you like love
that so but then when I found out that
people were actually made a petition
you've seen this oh yeah about there was
a group of people here it is on the
screen it has almost a hundred thousand
signatures I was looking at this last
night and it was going up before my eyes
which was cracking me up I'm like really
still going up go ahead pick up I was
going up as I was gonna go up right now
right we're live right I'm gonna get a
lot of meme signatures no yeah you're
right I mean I like I mean look it's I I
know all about this one of the things
about the transcription of the show
being in there is that it shows like
audience laughter it was like they're
including the people and by the way yeah
yeah I mean look at that I understood
people went through this so heavily it's
like I guess
why people get upset by like hearing
trigger words and stuff but you know the
first line of that it is you can't say
retain that's and people would message
me and say you know you can't say [ __ ]
anymore I go that's what I sat yeah
that's the setup to that is that you
can't even talk about how you can't talk
about it anymore yeah it was the perfect
moment of outrage yeah it was just like
it was there was a lot of outrage and
yeah I mean I knew listening to it that
there would be it's like just so obvious
then I met with with somebody who was
who was pretty outraged like they I
talked about which word about this this
whole whole whole the whole bit and
there go you know that petition also
calls for the the trailer to be taken
down everything yeah and the trailer
they Miss interpreted as being about
this when the joke and that is about
another yes so like good and then they
were telling me they're like in this
meeting and they're like I think a lot
of us got outraged we got we reacted to
the reaction in other words we didn't
look at it we didn't look it up I didn't
watch it lovely and I go and I'm sitting
there like don't you feel like you
should own that like that you didn't
watch it yeah and then you got mad yeah
and they're like kind of yeah okay but
then they made this point to me that I
kind of understood they go yeah but it
helped further our agenda so us going
after you even if it was not entirely
angley somewhere yeah they go it still
helped bring awareness to what our
ultimate goal is so even if we miss the
mr. mark a little bit the man's kind of
yeah so they're good I mean I you know I
don't here's a thing you can't feel bad
for yourself when the when the group is
this group and you go look you have it
hard enough already but but they also
were like we understand that the joke
wasn't to target you and [ __ ] on you it
just happened to be about words and
language yeah and it got spun into this
so like I don't I don't feel bad for
myself
I understand that what you're trying to
do but it wasn't lined up the way that
they initially thought it was and it was
mean even even in the joke you're like
well we didn't say it like that
right I gave the specific example factly
yeah we weren't like look at that guy
right which is I think exactly what you
said which it and like I pretty much I
don't think I can recall a time where
growing up or for that way anybody was
like pointing at something yeah point
someone can be like that guy yeah it was
always like to you yeah you know it's
like Ethan the [ __ ] man and then you
know you say to your friend about
something they did right but then of
course the reaction to that is like yeah
but you're just perpetuating you know a
hateful thing if you're saying you know
whatever that's that's how language
things change and progress over time
words take on different meanings
something becomes unacceptable and
pejorative and it goes away of course
the other conversation is then it's then
replaced with another word or term sure
so what that happens with all slurs and
all all words it's like we will outgrow
this word and then there will be a new
word you know like the one specifically
that really blows my mind yes like you
can't say [ __ ] anymore like I left it
Israel for five years yeah I came back
the world changed I couldn't say [ __ ]
anymore
yeah little people right I was like that
sounds way more condescending it sounds
to me like hey little guy yeah and by
the way I met I know little people who
find it demeaning little yes what did
you prefer some of them just don't even
want to be which makes the most no just
don't even it's laughs just a guy don't
make them but I mean it is you know I
guess voluntary on the airport I mean I
like I know most people I know black
guys girls we're cool with black but
there are those who say like call me
african-american it's like their own
voluntary I'm having a different
preference it's wild everybody but yeah
I mean I do I agree that little people I
was yeah I think I said midgets
how I'm passing and they're like it's a
little like people are super angry who's
like what are you kidding me I had to do
some research and look it up I was like
sure enough little I find that groups
have a much better sense of humor though
a little most part the little people yes
right yeah there are groups and that
have more egregious sense of humor
interesting yeah yeah Mexicans for
example I've heard from Alex oh like you
know Mexicans they never get they never
get upset they love it yeah I mean for
the most part how what you're I mean how
have you discovered that you met you if
you just doing shows every year and like
I've done shows Mex with a man [ __ ] with
me like just like they love it yeah man
like light me up doc you're like all
right it's LA they just want to go for
it yeah
can I ask you who is the most sensitive
can we go there I mean there's there's
uh I don't know older lesbians there's
no they're just group that's a tightness
you know it's funny because like we live
in such a quote liberal progressive City
I mean the most liberal progressive
people are not funny they don't they
take themselves too seriously they have
like that activist you know mentality
there's no humor in that show you know I
mean I'd rather do like rednecks than
that any day of the week if you're
talking about doing a show right because
they're gonna laugh at more [ __ ] you can
make fun of them you know do you have
these days problems it shows where
people are getting upset and walking out
or causing a scene if it's my like if
they bought it take it to my show that
doesn't really happen yeah if you just
pop in on a show I've had it happen a
few times in LA you know because we're
not other places
yeah but not I mean not a lot I mean el
you know la la is pretty good actually
for for stand-up you know the Comedy
Store is amazing The Improv but like the
store every night is just crazy with
with just comedy fans that one is he
stand-up most I'm going to that are not
going to be the type to be like ah that
cross the line because they they kind of
know where they're going they know they
see the line up they know what type of
people are on the line I'm you know I
heard bill bursts say something
interesting on his podcast he said like
now when I go on stage
saying crazier [ __ ] than I ever because
we were craving it because yeah yeah and
you also said it in an interview I think
I read oh they want it it's a release it
all is it's all connected though I mean
I think it's connected to you know it
goes to like who's in power what that
stands for what the blowback is against
who you know who they're pushing back
against and then that permeates the
feelings of people in public and then in
shows and it just it's this it's it's in
the air you feel it go back and forth
just like you feel a red or blue swing
in also interesting and it all kind of
ties in together there's a lot going on
and they're like the social oh yeah in
taters yes and like everything that's
going on all the little fabrics of
society are really channeling through
what you guys do absolutely yeah and you
can feel you sense it man that like if
if you're if you are like if you feel
like oh my god we're losing this
country's falling apart
you you you tend to take like a more
serious approach to everything and that
person also takes a serious approach to
commentary you know it's but then
there's a whole other group of people
who are like that's too much we're
losing our minds if we're getting yeah
and then those are the ones who want you
to say that real [ __ ]
so they yeah they come to the shows
wanting it to be like how come you
didn't offend us more you know I've had
people email they're like I really
thought well like you were gonna push it
harder I'm just doing stand up and be
like yeah and they're like yeah I really
was hoping you would like go harder and
I was like okay yeah no good know it man
and you know another one that blew me
away was like the same thing we went to
Israel we came back we had 4G LTE and
there were certain words I couldn't say
those a November I left when I came back
there was Ober all right now what Hoover
was so that was new to you yeah isn't
that funny man five years you were going
viewers it's a long time though five
years like yeah it isn't it's longer
than I thought I came back expected
everything no I remember studying abroad
for a semester in Spain and coming back
and being like have you heard this song
and people were like this song has been
out for a [ __ ] long time bro and like
and feeling like things were like I was
what happened like the country just like
escaped me I just I don't know what
happened but five years feel significant
I didn't realize you know I guess I was
keeping my head down in and slamming
away but these rallies kind of connected
so you don't feel that like you're not
like culturally or not yeah well I guess
I was but I guess you are still this how
long wait what years were you gone it
was actually I know because I recently
looked it up it was 2010 to 2015 yeah
that's when you came back yeah Wow bro
you just got here I guess we've argued
it for three years
oh my god yeah [ __ ] man but you guys
were doing this in Israel yeah yeah
really what my job I was working
full-time I quit my job cuz we're just
making youtube videos at the time okay
let's give it a shot you know you guys
seem so like down-to-earth and and
sincere are you blown away by what
you've created and and the following yes
yeah it's perfectly especially we're
like doing with a lot of like mental
barriers cuz it's like all of a sudden
you're like wait what is my life yeah
what happened it's do people close to
you get it what's going on like do you
know I mean a family they do now they do
in a while he was dad hated what I what
I did he's like a hard school boys what
really made it he's like you've married
this [ __ ] clown yeah that's a nice
way to put really yeah that beriin I
wish she said that what did he tell you
like like I'm embarrassed to tell people
that the best that's my son-in-law
really he's like because of what be
because of personality or what videos
videos there was one video back in the
day so at the time it never bothered me
that one because I don't know no wait
wait but there was one video at good
yeah
that was shake that thing not Paul was
very popular so I said yeah it's like a
parody shake that dick because you know
sure hey let's get some dick out there
I'm a little representation right this
is the new world right and so there was
just a lot of closer with my dick
hanging shaking and basketball shorts we
made a lot of videos but that happened
to be the one yeah I just I just put it
on my facebook yeah at the time I didn't
really know no one was following us
really made that I don't know 100 people
that was about but I put on my facebook
and and then on my dad's side yeah and
that after that it was really mad I
blocked him on Facebook he was really
mad yeah and what about when he would
would face to face was it cool to you
why he doesn't speak English
oh that's kind of what actually helps
sometimes just beginning Hebrew I mean a
little bit but long enough to like you
know what are you just like it's like
not about people who say they speak
Spanish yeah yeah yeah okay you know he
can order food in a restaurant yeah
that's all good that's what you gotta
fight I'd be like okay yeah okay so yeah
my favorite one was he said basically
I'm not gonna tell anyone that he's my
son law anymore wow there's an older
worse phone was like if I see another
video like that he's not gonna step in
the house something like that okay so
that's shake this dick though right or
shake that day out it's probably oh
you've got to shake that dick but I
don't know that we can show that I don't
very graph what about that aside was he
still upset like you're making videos
like this is just a stupid thing that
you guys are doing I mean aside from the
dick like the differing idea he sees
it's he sees it as vulgar he's just you
know my dad is very unplaced with
everything in life no it was just
another thing like I don't understand
what you guys are doing so I'm not
approving over that and what about now
so now loves it
I'll tell you what proud money helps
people I understand right now we're like
successful so it's like we can afford
proud of the problem bucketheads now
that's right it's like that but if we
you know it's pretty simple like
so now that you know yeah he's like cool
yeah but that makes sense he doesn't
it's a different world you understand
what we're doing
especially when I quit my job yeah I was
like you know now do you guys feel like
that do you feel like you are parallel
to show business being the the lane but
in other words being YouTube and and and
you know I mean or do you feel like
you're right there in it and some people
because it is like so massive you know
it's undeniable and you're in the
entertainment capital does it feel like
you're just a you know right next to no
I can you know I don't feel parallel
feel a whole different because a
different because like nobody is
involved with what we do know how it's
just us we don't any which is the desk
it is women it's the best part of
podcasting period yeah I take it for
granted cuz we've never had any other
way but like all of our videos
everything we do we have a clothing
company there's nobody but I want
answers I came for that teddy fresh swag
I'm here man last we got we have worth
swag down wagon up oh yeah well at any
rate it feels different it feels
different and I guess well mostly
because there's not nobody's really
crossing over mm mm like traditional
media is not really they're not really
understanding it know and they're not
really tapping into it I think that
there's just ahead of the game on a tall
man I don't know I feel I feel we have a
lot to offer like I think that when a
guest comes on our show
mm-hmm the press and publicity and like
exposure that they get is way more than
like Jimmy Kimmel for example I feel
like that's measurably factually true
but for some reason yeah you know you
have there's no trouble getting people
though do they they have to see what you
guys do and be like oh my god we don't
have the we don't have the contacts we
don't have the
you know we don't have all those
channels that like you get we're gonna
talk about something yeah but I also
think part of it is just that we I don't
know
the podcast is only a year old so it's
not it doesn't like deep roots or
anything yeah the whole thing's don't
use like 2013 Bros we talk right five
years it's great it you could say you
could you could almost say [ __ ] back
then almost yeah I preferred our work I
want to know about em word
what's the M word marijuana wait we're
we're editing that we're having
marijuana downside ampulla trying I
don't know win not because it was racist
against mexican-americans because
marijuana is a is Spanish I guess
marijuana huh and so they might he won
yeah yeah it was used to discriminate to
demonize Mexicans Mexicans eat marijuana
for breakfast well that okay well I
guess here here you go
I'll give you a little taste of the of
the term what races are as saying
marijuana why because it's racist ass
color and their devilish ways now the
word itself is an inherently racist but
it was used by American prohibitionist
okay this is why people are losing their
mind exactly and coming to the Bill burr
show and being like say some wild [ __ ]
because this is and there's another one
where I go is this a parody video the
digital blackface one did you see that
one yeah yeah video you did yeah okay I
was like I was real oh yeah no that
one's below the way I keep hearing about
it like I heard it on BBC about like
doing a blackface like these gifts I've
our alter ego that I don't called white
face man that I hover myself in like my
man here you go dude the the craziest
part about the like the commentary as
fantastic
the crazy part about the commentary
about digital blackface was that you
know it says something she said
something like stop and think before you
send that gift
right yeah of you know Kevin Hart right
your friend it's not that's not for our
amusement entertainment and it's like
that's how you know that is just because
he's here for our amusement
entertainment but it's not it's not like
you're just taking random footage of
black dudes on the street no that's a
thing from his special when I duty to
laugh at oh man they kept showing
entertainers the way the whole the whole
scheme was like that thing looks crazy
that guy being less racist is [ __ ] so
his point anyway is that like let's say
call the M word and if you really want
to be politically correct call it
cannabis okay I don't want to be so just
for the right hair what else yeah let's
not take that one away I think we should
start all emphasizing that it's
marijuana yeah
all right let's let's throw it to a
quick break okay and we will be right
back with the great hilarious and
wonderful Tom Segura all the specials
out on Netflix and he's on tour guys
we'll be right back
you have definitely heard me talking
about me and East you know the fun comfy
undies that feel as good as they look
yeah Exhibit A please to those of you
who haven't tried them listen up you can
get incredible underwear sent to your
door with me on these meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a
crowded store and eventually settling
for good enough mandis are made with the
sustainably sourced material from
beechwood trees people we are cutting
down forests to bring you these
underwear okay but Beach it sounds
exotic I'll say that they're naturally
soft fiber make a fabric that won't snag
down or ride up and trust me once you
put on a pair you'll get it now what I'd
like to say is please turn to Exhibit B
ela to show us how flexible and
breathable rideable these undies are
that's an atomic wedgie
that's the h3 atomic wedgie challenge
get a pair of me undies and give
yourself an atomic wedgie and send us
pictures because I guarantee
doesn't even hurt wow you got like
everything tucked right in there yeah
I'm telling you can tuck everything
right in there and you won't even notice
it's the atomic poison challenge it's
almost like giving your genitals a
massage
am i right either yes there you have it
from from the mouth from ear mouth
itself
Mandy's the show sure you're gonna love
your first pair that if you're not happy
they'll do whatever you can they can to
get you into the right pair and if they
can't keep them and you'll don't refund
you so it really is risk free to try the
best underwear ever made and if you're
already part of the me undies fam tell
your friends about it through the
referral program they'll get a discount
and you'll get store credit when when
mother effers offer how about this for
first-time purchasers get 15% off their
first pair of Mandy's and free shipping
Dean 1/5 mother effers that's 50% off
plus free shipping and guarantee that
you and your me undies will be very
happy together so get your butts over to
me Andy's calm and treat yourself to get
50% of your first pair you look go ahead
an atomic wedgie one more time
50% of your purse pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guaranteed yeah you
could tuck your head right in there if
you wanted to
that's how breathable and flexible these
are these are I'm wearing like Ethan
Zohn go to me Andy's calm /h I just want
to get the URL in there me Andy's calm
/h 3 that's me Andy's calm /h 3 it's
gonna take your junk it's gonna smooth
it out I have this problem mice junks
everywhere it itches
it chafes the beltline messes up my skin
this doesn't do that because it's soft
it's made from beechwood tree give
yourself an atomic wedgie you're gonna
love it thank you to hims for sponsoring
this episode
sexual performance issues are more
common than you think you'e okay and and
you experience it a lot over 25% of new
IDI cases are guys under 40 that's
shocking 40% of men by the age 40
struggle from not being able to get a
fat hard [ __ ]
to put in a hole even the world's
greatest actors can't fake one why do
you guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing when you can turn instead to
medicine and science that can inject
some energy into your God flow you're
blowing it down you wanna dump your
blood flow it's just it makes your blood
flow to your penis for hips calm a
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men thanks to
science edie can be optional helps
connect you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
limp dick well known generic equivalents
to name-brand prescriptions to help you
combat
edie this is not snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements I see those
all the time the gas stations dragon
bill it's like 20 bucks it's like the
weirdest [ __ ] from China God god forbid
the desperate man who actually eats
whatever one that we bought just go to
the package it's like 3d it is not that
prescription solutions backed by science
so there's no waiting room no awkward
doctors at no lines save hours by going
to four hands calm so easy answer a few
quick questions and chat with a doctor
for a confidential review products are
shipped directly to your door being your
best means performing your best with a
fat raging boner I don't know if it does
I think it I don't know what it does how
would I know what it does is go ahead
dr. Klein doctor it helps relax blood
vessels and improves blood flow to your
benefit what are you reading Wow
there you go to allow for a harder and
long-lasting erection longer either side
is thinking about signing me up for this
no in-person doctor is it not anymore
it's a wreck tile with other dysfunction
hard made easy
say hello friend they told me to say
that's pretty creepy but I'll do it call
to action try aims for a month today for
just five dollars
I said doll hairs but they do expect
money from you will get you started for
just five bucks while supplies last see
website for full details this because
100 of bucks do you want to a doctor or
pharmacy so go to for him
calm / h3e d that's fo r hims calm / h3e
d forbes.com / h3e d to get that blood
flowing and get that [ __ ] what what is
the word EULA flowing close that damn
going going I'm going yeah yeah thanks
thanks to them truth is most of us are
brushing our teeth wrong
not for long enough and forget to change
our brush on time that's because most
Brent focus on selling flashy gimmicks
rather than better brushing but not quit
so what makes quip so different let me
tell you for starters it's pretty good
yo are you good where are we quick is an
electric toothbrush nice that's a
fraction of the cost is the camera
merula
I think you should listen y'all know I
have to give quip a ceremonial entrance
angelic one if you will because this
toothbrush not only changed my life but
it changed the world why do you think
Oprah's got it on her o list it's not
because it's a vibrating tube with multi
purpose o list this toothbrush changed
my life and the world let me tell you
why it's slick it's modern it's
affordable it gives you the best brush
possible I'm obsessed with oral hygiene
if my mouth is gross or anyone else I'm
with I'll judge you I swear to God I
will judge you okay so don't be that guy
get this toothbrush it gives you a
perfect brush vibrating wonderful it
tells you when to switch sides so you
always know that you're getting the
perfect brush now I know why Oprah was
like oh it's a quick it's the toothbrush
that's killing it and will change your
life forever okay what else
clip starts at just $25 and you go get
quick calm so I say it's true right now
you can get your first refill pack free
with equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill back free and
when you know are they always like at
the end of commercials now you're
supposed to accentuate that bug
it's GE t qu IP dot-com / h3 get quipped
calm / h3 I guarantee it you go try this
toothbrush you're gonna be hearing this
music every morning thank you to quit
Wow those were some really good sponsor
reads right Gila all right
killing it you guys are great I want to
ask you I love this story I heard you
tell about how you almost got pitched as
Jared's no fish lavash younger meatball
eating brother and I love this story so
much because basically you were like you
thought it was your big break
I knew it was my big right I knew I was
25 mmm why are you 25 you're doing a day
job here
what were you doing at the time I was
working in post as a reality shows you
were editing no I wasn't editing I was a
at first I was a logger like
transcribing what's a logger there's so
many jobs it's great it's the worst job
you want employers write a [ __ ] no no
they sent you the raw tape so they you
know when they shoot a reality for seven
cameras run so they send you every
single tape comes in and it's
transcribed verbatim so that when the
story department puts together a reality
show an episode they can manipulate all
the footage so you're just a field
discovering every dumb thing they said
if you say I don't know I guess I'll go
I have to write I don't know like that
Wow
and then you know they do these things
called Franken bites you know what
that's where you cut a line mid-sentence
and piece something else together to it
so that you can say because we making
bits because we always say like this a
Frankenstein sequence you know when we
haven't always [ __ ] it up yeah the MD
building a mom they do horrific stuff
with it you know because you would say
like I love shredder and then I hate you
know I don't know pumpkin pie and then
they'll cut it to it I hate shredder and
then everyone the always like like I
hates his dog and then they show their
actions from other people from a
different clip you know yeah and exactly
and then that's the episode there's and
then the reaction people are like oh my
god I always think about that because
it's like you're filming people doing
nothing
yeah you've got it needs work yeah he's
a lot of work and he's a lot of work
then those there's people who in that
Lane that
is their specialty it's the story
Department on reality Rankin Stein they
[ __ ] Frank and by that I'm just
typing us and really it's horrible and
I'm doing stand-up at night and then
going on sometimes on commercial
auditions when I go on this one and I
got a callback which I thought was cool
and then they're like hey this isn't
just for a commercial this is for a
campaign hmm meaning this will be airing
and massively and all the time and it
will build and grow and then the next
thing they tell me is like it's gonna be
it's with subway and the idea is you're
gonna be Jared's brother Jared Fogle
from Subway and and Jared because he
lost like 500 pounds can only promote
healthy subs and we need someone that
can promote unhealthy subs and you look
like you can do that I love that I love
you know it's like so directly and at
first I know me that I was like yeah
great and they're like so he'll be like
get the turkey sub and you'll be like
get the chicken parm and like that'll be
the ad yeah and then they're go and
you're gonna be like his derelict
[ __ ] psycho brother so I go to this
one audition where this is like now the
third or fourth cuz this is a huge
commitment from them this one that's
like all improv and they're having me
improvise and with like this director
what do you do they have you in would
you know your outfit would have been no
because at first they just go they're
just like you know just show up and
you're a pig basically you know I'm just
wear a t-shirt and jeans and and I'm
riffing and I and I remember my friend
drove me to the audition even though I
don't know why he drove me but he was
outside and I left he goes you're booked
in this job I go why he goes man they
were laughing in there so hard and I was
like yeah I don't know man I don't know
so we leave and then I have another
callback and it's with the director and
it's just weird
it just doesn't it's just weird he's
like like do what I tell you to do do
okay be like hey yeah it's taste pretty
good good you want me to say yeah that
taste no no say hey that's taste pretty
good hey then no I say hey hey
okay he's pretty good hey hey hey that's
how he's talking to me during it so I'm
like I'm sitting there like this guy's
cutting me off every other sentence to
say like things taste good you know like
it's not like I'm doing a take and he's
like try it from this angle he's doing
line reads as I do them so I just go
alright and I walk out of there I'm like
that was one of the weirdest experiences
it just didn't feel you know like this
man interaction no and it wasn't good
chemistry it wasn't good a good vibe I
leave whatever and the next day I get a
call and they're like so we heard it
didn't go well in there and I was like
what did they want from you I don't know
oh god I don't know what I'm supposed to
do Hey I started to do it like that
taste really good is that it and so then
they're like but you did so well
on the audition before that and the
producers and the advertisers are so on
board with you from that that you booked
it director hates you so you got the job
yeah and then they go I'll just tell you
I don't think I've ever said it but so
the the the what I got was a guarantee
of 250 grand for the whole campaign no
no just like peak for shooting this and
having one heir Wow Wow but then some
cheddar then as soon as the residuals
exceed so you know more money until the
residuals exceed 250 and then you get
residual checks and then I'll start
getting checks for live appearances
where Jared and I will go insane and
Jared holds up his pants for a lot of
parents I don't know I think they were
saying like you were gonna get something
like 10 or 15 grand I'll show up but
mind you yourself wait then 25 years old
transcribe that's huge
oh no that button like $600 a week to do
that yeah so when I when they booked it
they go you know I'm kind of waiting for
it to come together and then they said
we're gonna start shooting
commercials in Jersey they fly me out we
shoot three commercials over the course
of like a week what were you wearing I'm
really curious
so the first ad where they just like be
yourself man if you know uh no they're
like it you know that song round and
round yeah
I forget who sings that round baby right
not right not right baby round it's like
oh rocks a hat or something yes yes yes
yes so I pull up in a Trans Am this song
is playing and they're having a family
reunion and I pull up that song's
playing and I have like a leather vest
on and like maybe like a like a leather
wrist thing and some chains love it and
as I pull into the it's like a park and
they're having a family reunion I kind
of have pull onto a curb you know like I
pull too far yeah and then I get out I'm
like you're almost like a bad boy yeah
kind of a bad boy but totally and
chicken parmesan the in bad boy yeah the
chicken all right bad boy kind of but
also lost in time I'm like where's
everybody at
you know I heard about this angle yeah
like who's gonna want to be that guy
they're like eat chicken parm like this
guy right it's a weird angle that is a
weird angle and like you want to be this
guy and kind of and he's and they're
kind of that kind of they are being
telling me like be be dumb you're kind
of the you're the goofy brother right
that's like that hasn't seen Jared in a
while of course they're named your
estranged from the family yesterday yeah
and now you just came back to eat bad
food and then of course they gave me oh
the name your Jerez brother Jerome
that's dumb and which is you know and
the fact I brought up to them I was like
yeah that's the recipe play I have to
say were you nervous about bringing up
because you said to the producers or the
director yeah
Jerome seems like a black name yes let
you guys know yeah Jermaine no they I
was I was not nervous to tell them that
I was not nervous I was like you're
doing the right thing I just thought I
was I go like we're about to launch onto
a this is gonna be what people yell at
me on the street and for here and you
know they told me they go you know
we're shooting three right now were
slated to do ten if these have any these
are Jarrod's in them so if this is
following the trajectory yours can be
shooting like thirty commercials a year
or whatever your life or year I'm like
Jerome I'm like - come on so I just saw
him like dude that's a black guys like
it is and I mean I know the the people
would be like it could be anybody's name
that's true
so can Connor that could be anybody's
name but it's not it's a [ __ ] white
guy's name yeah so they go alright you
know we'll think about it what's hotter
and we'll talk to you and then they came
back and they're like we think you're
right I love that they make the great
minds getting together the subway might
have indeed confirmed we have our own
news block excuse black you nailed it
anyone could have it yeah but it's less
black excuse black yeah we got your new
name - Jermaine and I just sat there I
go are you serious
and they go yeah I mean this 10 times
blacker and they were just like that's
your name final answer final answer
Jermaine's here worse way worse which
was like okay so then we just we shot
that one in that Park then we shot one
where I was like oh yeah I remember um I
was having I had a basement band I was
like guys come on and like you know I
had like we were just like a shitty
basement band I was the lead man in like
chair was show up be like what are you
doing Jermaine and I'm like [ __ ]
let's eat we we shot that one I remember
there's another one and then it was just
you know then you're just like playing
the waiting game like a flew back I'm
they pay for those because well you I
got paid all the the day rate stuff to
do those the two or 50 grand I would get
as soon as the first one when I aired
right and it was like a few months later
and I remember one of my friends texted
me he was like sucks about Subway he
found out before you uh-huh
and I go what do you mean he's like
you're not doing those ads I'm like how
do you know that huh wait was this the
sex scandal no oh no this is way back
when you know I don't know how he found
out but what happened was the VP of
Marketing yeah
retired Oh the new VP came in and wasn't
down on it well he just killed
everything that that guy was doing it
was the greatest thing that ever
happened was no no they were just like I
have weird new there's a new marketing
team and that's it's very common in
corporate world where if the new guy
doesn't want your old idea succeed you
know he wants it to be on yeah on him so
and especially if it sucks he can't be
you know he got to be like I I scratch
that but anyways I informed my agent I
called him and I was like so the subway
things that happened he was the [ __ ] are
you talking about uh-huh and I'm like
dude I just read this article and then
he called me back he's like yeah yeah I
just called him and they that break your
heart at the time yeah I mean it wasn't
like this you know life-changing breakup
thing where but I remember just being
like wow that was right here it's gone
and one mm I mean like yeah that but in
retrospect surely you're just like think
I'm gone
Jermaine everybody French man as I walk
down the streets another like yeah but
not only that I mean you'd be associated
with the greatest Fogel the greatest
Fogel of all time mr. mogill hung out
with him after one of those shoots huh
you get a weird vibe what was Fogle like
in person yeah I mean no I can't I mean
he's not not just like a normal loose
dude okay you know I don't know how to
describe I mean he's one of those guys
that should never became famous yeah
it's weird that he's what I think is
right I think he's just so used to being
probably looked at and asked for a
picture or something and there's not a
lot behind that you know that you know
it's just because he lost weight and
he's on these commercials so yeah he's
just kind of like do you think when you
heard those tapes were you like
surprised so really I just remember I
remember you know the are the things I
remember where is that like for the for
the commercials that I got a shitty
trailer like a
shitty one he had like a
multimillion-dollar bus he was like do
you want to come on this bus and I was
like I want to see it for sure yeah and
I got on I remember he just had it was
in the summer in Jersey that we were
shooting these commercials and his his
bus had like 60 degree AC on it and I
was like I stay in here it was I
remember that was amazing and then I
remember his friend was with him and he
was complaining about that the subway
execs were talking about how he was
gaining weight they were upset they were
like I love that like it's [ __ ] man
is but he's like you look great Jer to
Jerry he's like he's got yes but being
like you're not fat yeah and then he
goes do you want split a pizza
thanks for real yeah and I go okay what
so we're at the W Hotel and he ordered
pizza Wow yeah I have bet there was
something in his contract was like you
can eat pizza
of course yeah yeah yeah and they were
like you can't be seen eating other fast
foods
Jarrid phenomenon is so crazy like
they're treating them like royalty he's
just a guy that lost weight any
sandwiches it just blows my mind to this
day like phenomenal Jerry did you I was
by Darrell I've never seen it it's why I
think that marketing campaign really did
a lot for Subway because I was during
the five foot though I don't live long
if I don't follow those loves those
things do not continue without being
successful you know I'm saying that a
campaign yeah he was their spokesman for
15 a lot of Subway during those years
yeah and it wasn't healthy subway either
no you got here the Jermaine so I got
how ya doing yeah no he was um he lucked
out crazy on getting that gig of what
she made what's his net worth I'm gonna
look that up I think it was ahead of you
yeah
you
so he'll just be one all right folks
Jared Fogle gotten our Internet yeah
from prison he just hacked into this
stream
oh you think Jared was behind it I'm
sure I don't have a single doubt about
it wait here I can see us right now
we're live I think we're back okay whoo
we are back our conversation was on a
whole conversation not our whole
conversation I don't know about Jared
Jared getting our [ __ ] no no what are we
today did they get us up saying the N
word about your time [ __ ] [ __ ] can you
cut that out I don't think we can cut
that out can I say that you said it yeah
we said it was just us all right so
we're good down we can continue as we
were yeah it looks like yeah it looks
like we're when did that happen you uh
just now I said that anyway that was
dramatic the internet dropped out but
apparently we're back I was just looking
up Fogle can maybe he could tweet out
that we're back live or some man cares
I'll do it don't figure they know what
they know the rules Jared Fogle's net
worth is 15 million you guessed it guess
15 milli it's good Gesine sandwich just
saying I love that he was in his trailer
take a walk yeah it's all he did do you
think he like he lost 500 pounds though
actually you see I don't know there was
five I might be good but I mean it was
over 300 pounds yeah it was a lot a lot
god bless him he just for them it was
supposed to be a it was a men's health
article so he it was just like a thing
where of this guy who was super obese
lost bunch of weight by going on walks
and it wasn't that subway was weight
loss food he was like I just I would
walk and go get a 6-inch sub a veggie
Delite erson yeah and then I would keep
walking and I did this every day
wait and that was an ad and subway saw
it was like we should run a commercial
really I like goddamn and that just you
know took off from there damn all the
work he did man yep
he had the easiest ride in life but he
had to be a [ __ ] pedophile piece of
sh I was like the biggest one of the
great pedophile twists of history yeah I
mean now you guys see a lot of this but
this is one of the great ones that's one
of the great downs like when you look at
a kind of like always a twist
well no when you look at a guy like
Jimmy Savile you like that guy
definitely rapes kids yeah
but Jarrod yeah I mean I guess I
definitely didn't see it coming but he
have some creepy he's got high quality -
yeah yeah well god bless man glad that
you dodged that hole after that 6-inch
sandwich not J yeah I never would have
been able to shake that man was wearing
for years and years think it even if you
went on to be successful as I'm sure you
would it would just be like this great
meme about yeah yeah the story is so
good and I do I have I do want to see
the commercials I was thinking like oh
you know if you can get in touch with
the right person you could get them then
I realized that's evidence well yeah
it's well it's just that there's no like
because he's in it it was I'm sure it's
it's a little stranger yeah you like
telling this story no who's that no they
can't gonna do now
yeah you know and they killed it did
today in their defense they do you know
why they killed it that all I always
heard was just the marketing the
marketing VP all right yeah yeah that's
it I sell I think I was told
yeah I heard you tell a story another
great one from from from what was it
disgraceful right about you uh being fat
saved your life when you overdosed
no that was on this is not happening are
years right right was that on me son
yeah yeah
I love that story so much you overdose
on drugs mm-hmm when you were freshmen
in college and the doctor says being fat
saved your life is basic
or one of the two only times being fast
in life and I wanted to say because it
it struck in me our memory of a fat guys
whose life was saved because he was fat
and it stuck with me I wanted to share
that story what is it I was watching
cops mm-hmm and there was a guy who was
stabbed like by a six-inch really brutal
blade mm-hm and the cop is like how like
you choked shows up and the guy's just
sitting there he's completely fine he's
huge he's old beasts massives got he got
stabbed with a six-inch blade didn't
touch though the vital bomb he was told
if he was just sitting there having
anything at all good and so I thought to
myself he was fat and I saved his life
dude in in the commercials for why you
should be fatty should tell these
stories there's you know there's benefit
they should be like do you get stabbed
it won't hit any vital right and if you
take a lot of drugs good chance you live
through it
be fat that should be the commercial
right be fat yeah it was it was mine was
like they were just like you should
definitely be dead right that's you know
when they were looking at the toxicology
and I was like why am I not dead then
and they're like because you're like 255
pounds and like that's the only we can
think that you've lost a lot of weight
since then since then yeah I mean I
actually lost a lot of weight after that
and kept it off for a few years gained
all that back and then some and then
lost part of that again yeah up and down
so real healthy for your system I know I
didn't do I'm always like that it's so
hard I'm like I'm a naturally fat guy no
always battling I yeah Greg Fitzsimmons
told me he goes you're built to be fat
that's what he said to me I was like
guys a great title or day to be fat is a
great title yeah man I don't know I mean
now I'm just I'm really trying to
maintain you know like with try to avoid
sugar as much as I can if like that was
like my big thing without one sugars
just it's just horrible debate about
stuff all the time sugars poison sugars
poisoned without without question yeah
and the sugar lobby is enormous and
that's what you know it's a powerful
powerful lobby I lose my mind sometimes
because I try to cut on a sugar too at
the grocery store there's sugar and
[ __ ] everything like you can't even
find bread I'm that's one thing that
drives me crazy
in Israel the bread is not sweet and why
should it be sweet it's mature it's
bread and here it's I can't stand
there's someone who's like five grams of
sugar there's sometimes like seven grams
of sugar what I want I want it so badly
I want that sweet bread all of it I want
our science no one treats cookies
brownies it's [ __ ] I want pancakes
waffles yeah I wanted all men pasta come
on I wanted all the time
but yeah I try to avoid it you know as
much as I can
sometimes I'll go without having it for
like a month more than like I only have
incidental sugar sometimes you know but
that and then act let me I've been a
workout trainer now I didn't boxing
other than are you working out four days
a week
wow that's a lot yeah are you actively
still on the decline
weight-wise I felt like I hit a plateau
recently and then I increased the
workouts a couple weeks ago where do you
do it is I'm like in a gym in a gym I go
to a small gym where you just do like
one-on-one training so we start doing
that but I found that it was I liked it
I go on like sometimes too which i think
is great
you know great if you and your outside
you'd like that's uphill you're doing
pretty intense cardio I don't know it's
uh it's always a battle though man you
know I feel like yeah like five days
away from it all falling I know I like
that people like ela she's just like
it's so easy for skinny people like you
I have that do just put down the fork no
but I understand cuz I I've been trying
to gain weight before like I get a load
of this I know get a load I have been
trying though and I'm not succeeding so
I understand the cyclic of not
succeeding to make a stupid change like
gain weight what's the problem I don't
know what's the problem well we have
different you know systems and basically
her you know her body just processes it
completely differently it's basically a
more efficient system you know I feel
like she's just not humped like I I feel
like double hump yes I crave and desire
hamburgers and pizza yeah every [ __ ]
yeah I'm with you brother they could dry
yeah it's it is it's not like it I used
to think I've says before I used to
think that people that weren't fat just
didn't like food you know but it's kind
of true I don't know I don't think they
like it as much as us
I think mmm it's not a did we have more
of an addiction than them but I still
know a a lot of them a lot of them like
some of them are just healthy and no
like oh you shouldn't eat garbage all
the time yeah and then that kind of is
unlikely to be around I think about a
lot is it an issue of self control or we
kind of genetically well both yeah we're
genetically weaker or you know were
inclined to be alcoholics for example
yeah but I think we you know it's a
matter of efficiency - like your your
body you know some some bodies are like
perfectly engineered for food and if you
get the sugar spike it just processes
everything effectively and efficiently
and then there's you know like there's
there's the super obese where it's like
that's a that's where the efficiency is
completely off right and then there's
like in-between my god he did yeah
remains
Jermaine's yeah the Jane of the world
yeah it's just like you're just like
goddamn it's actually worse right when
you're like like me or you're just like
[ __ ] like you're just hanging on like
it's just steps away from falling off
the other route I used to have a
roommate in college who was like you'd
like very thin that dude and he was just
dying to gain weight yeah he would eat
he would try to eat and gain weight then
would make shakes and we get one day we
we were counting the calories needed
like 12,000 calories yeah yeah and it
just didn't matter wouldn't gain his
body I was just like no ya wouldn't gain
a pound you know in nature we were the
survivors we are right yeah well yeah
cause if I got overdose of drugs oh yeah
I would be like gone yeah or if you
can't find food out no I'll leave right
stock up yeah I'll tell you what with in
the zombie apocalypse we're gonna be
will be the survivors that's right die
eventually it'll take a while but we'll
get to have the pleasure of seeing all
of our loved ones die first flesh
yeah you'll be tribal leaders yeah yeah
well we'll be survivors I'm sure you
know the other thing I really related to
in that story is how the first thing
after you find out you not that it's
like the first thing you were worried
about is if your parents are mad at you
oh yeah it's so much like how I live it
was my first panic it was panic when I
came to I was in a coma I didn't know I
was in a coma
I guess I'm literally I'm looking at
ceiling lights and I see this doctor who
I know it's my friend's mother oh and
she sees me come to and she's like
you're in the hospital I was like and I
have tubes in my mouth and my arms are
restrained I call this year putting
together he has it happened like like
you're in the hospital she was you
overdosed and you're in the hospital but
we're taking care you know mm-hmm and
then I just see my parents coming my
whole thought was like do they know do
they know what I did yeah oh yeah and
they were like yeah and I wrote that
down to my I really drove down to him
are you mad at me
which like looking back on it makes me
like feel bad for me as that kid like
it's kind of a sweet thought very and
you know are you mad at me to your dad
yeah and him looking reading and going
like just disappointed yeah is like
you're alive and death yeah did you make
the joke I wondered about heroin you
overdosed on heroin I said what you
overdose on you said heroin yeah you did
that I did do that yeah I really did do
that I was like the part that I didn't
do I think in the in real life was right
JK but I did write heroin and people
were like oh yeah of course
like I'm just killed and yeah but to be
joking in that you had yeah and yeah
even back then oh that's a special
moment Jackie Jo yeah in writing on a
nope in writing with the wrong hand I'm
left-handed I wrote in
right hand like yeah I'm like ha ha ha
[Laughter]
so you on your podcast you guys talk
about Browntown a lot yeah and all that
yeah we do too
you do to them a lot of we gotta go on a
double date
I want to ground the cover and what's
Tina's favorite favorite it's mine he
was not so much into it I can't stop
talking about it it's just my life the
just resigned to it
you know he's not up for another reason
your father's upset he talked about poop
all the time but he won't like that
either it wasn't like I wasn't talking
about poop before we got married
no you were it wasn't like we got
married and alls it's all the sudden I
was like yeah let me tell you about my
one of our presence on YouTube was you
talking about how your wife really and
yeah and it's and it's a debate that
lasts to this day so I wanted to ask you
some wiping and pooping questions if you
don't mind absolutely
ok good so first of all tell me do you
use baby wipes no but I do I have used
baby wipes a white pack outside of the
house at that house fantastic if that's
your if you're out in public
yeah and I have used baby wipes in in
some situations like you know the new
habit you start attacking and what but
the best by far is having a bidet or a
wash light I don't get the but did the
great debate we have on this podcast is
baby wipes first bidet I don't get the
bidet and I feel like you're a hairy guy
like me oh it's the sky having their
hairy [ __ ] yeah and I don't
understand this process we have a bidet
in our new house yeah and I've squirted
water on my I've tried it ok this is the
update people are waiting for yeah
everybody's I don't get it because it
doesn't really clean the [ __ ] it just
sprays and then and then like how do you
because you put toilet paper on the
[ __ ] and there's all this hair here
just bunches up and you've got a [ __ ]
paper mache oh I hear it come over and
[ __ ] in my house ok yes are you gonna be
there with me too walk me through why
yes REO tell me okay so first of all you
have we have you have different speeds
different temperatures are you doing
like we have a different temperatures is
every temperature sit yeah awesome okay
no no but I'll tell you it's squirt it's
like you're at amateur hour I need to
come over okay so I'm having another new
one installed tomorrow yeah I have to
total wash let eat 350s
not sponsors but I'm probably product
okay and then take know yes about a bio
bidet sent me another one that's the one
going in tomorrow so the these total
wash let's are game-changers I mean you
guys the price tag I think I think what
I heard was I went to one of their
wholesale outlets and they told me this
I was like could we rented a house once
for a year that had one so we bought our
house I was one you needed it we are not
moving in here without this yeah and I
mean like look at my chest right it's
like I mean why take a [ __ ] it's like I
have this it'd be like somebody just
took a [ __ ] birthday cake and smashed
it on my chest clean it up with a piece
of paper you know but that okay go ahead
so debate anyways you have the remote
here right the wall on the wall and you
can take it out and hold it if you go I
think I think the wholesale this is what
they told us the the wholesale place
said like it's like 1500 or something
like that if you go order it from their
company and that Amazon had them new not
used for close to that used no I'm
saying I was making the point said it's
Amazon but it's a new but I mean if you
want to buy a mine that's fine
so I'm we've got okay we've got a
reference here is what we thought you
said the 350 right so while it bidet
toilet seat Auto open and clean there's
just the seat my dude no there's the
remote next to it there and yeah this is
Amazon's
Joe absolutely
so wait a minute so you press your
button yeah they have rear or front wash
right because it women a lot of women
refer the front wash yeah on the front
the back you ever double up
I don't double up I do use the dryer and
dryer yeah so what I do is there's soft
pressure so I'll run that at first right
and just let that no toilet paper at all
I mean sometimes if you feel like this
is a real mud but I'll do like a curb
item yeah
were you just like I don't look I'm just
let's get some of that chunk on you
don't love it then I'm gonna peek at it
no I always pee least take one look
sometimes I do but sometimes I'm like
that's a disaster and I'll just do like
a cursory wipe I'll do the soft run
which is warm but kind of soft water for
a while and then I'll do a white yeah a
little tease right yeah and then I'll do
a wipe and I'm like is there more
business to be done here or not and if
there is wait wait you give it a soft
right give it and just let it run and
then you give it a wipe then I give it
away how do you wipe their area like how
long do you how do you wipe a wet hairy
ass well this is the X variable that I
don't I think I think it's just a matter
of you don't want it to be too thin so
maybe you know you wrap your hand a
little bit right so there's a little
thickness right what you're wiping with
Ray right and then your Y feel like a
dab or you get in there depends on the
on the day but like who today I did hot
ones right yeah it's very fiery ass full
of a day yeah I mean it was it's been
kind of gnarly so now that watch there's
no towel involved is there what's that
there's no towel involved towel
yeah no no they [ __ ] breaks they use
a towel that's another I don't
understand they take a white towel your
brother is one of them he's what he's
telling me he's got a towel that he
dries off his ass home like bro you have
a shitty [ __ ] in your bathroom while
you're calling me that's what I know
this is what I don't understand but days
that's why is this what the Israeli
people are like no a lot of people do
the bidet towel I'm telling you they
have shitty hand towels
great on the wall and I never knew that
and uh he's not the only one they'd use
a washcloth in the shower yeah
just remember a kid staying at someone's
house and they're like I'm gonna take a
shower like here's a washcloth and
you're like I'm not poor like what are
you talking about dude I know so I don't
love whatever I say that people get so
thank you I knew that about you just
looking at yeah or just say that to like
I knew that about yeah cuz you're a
little strange you're a little strange
yeah so okay back to the wipe though so
we got you get that that soft run goes
you wipe okay then if there's still
something there then I go I hit the the
it hard yes and then it's like a little
bit like a fire hose yeah it really revs
it up and I'm telling you if you're a
hairy dude that thing I love clean you
up so the big day that I've got think
more like a veg wash it's nothing it's
just like a faucet and you're okay I add
that lamb no this is like the pressure
real pressure heat which is important
need to have warm to hot water doing
this I'm gonna [ __ ] at my house bro
come over there you wanna test drive
yeah take you first buy it
absolutely well we're reporting back on
the park I is this seat heated yes and
of course also here's oh my god
I discovered this on accident with that
thing first of all the lid opens
automatically when you walk in to the
room right so the lid is there so if you
want to say if you want to sit down
great but here's the other thing that
remote that remote the top of it which
is mounted to your wall lifts the seat
so when you go you just push it and it
goes that so you never have to lift up I
see didn't I mean I can jump knowledge
that you call plumber to install it you
can have a handyman a plumber because
someone's got to put their hands in a
toilet bowl yeah it's nice to clean it
for them a little bit but yeah I know I
guess I'm not I'm not imagining it's not
legit stains in it but I know and wrote
I sat down okay today so I had gnarly
morning you know hot ones dude anyway
yeah yeah a couple weeks but so I went I
think twice you know I was like as bad
man and then I'm getting ready to come
here and I'm like
man still feeling the rescission I just
I gotta check out how do you know I did
I just sat on that I didn't do anything
I just sat down and let water run there
for a while cool it off and then I
checked out I mean you know 15 20
seconds I was just like oh I mean you
can let it run till it stops running
which I've done it's got some kind of
tank yeah it's got like a mechanism well
it's just like I think it's after a
minute he'll just shut down what do you
feel like when it runs out of water
what's the fit you're like ah I mean
yeah you disappointed you feel a little
disappointed get them to sit and wait
for it to recharge no no you just press
it right away again yeah so that it
doesn't just keep running like it takes
a breath yeah yeah yeah it's another
goes right back work yeah this makes me
think of George Costanza because it was
always like in the chase of the perfect
the perfect public toilets are like
silent but this is like the perfect
toilet I like I'm doing this if you
tried it yesterday I had a break between
that and something else and [ __ ]
trying to take a [ __ ] in Hollywood in
midday is one of most horrible
experiences I can imagine
I mean like what specifically holy what
specifically is mad enough yeah I mean
even if you go in there man
you want to see Starbucks and how I
wouldn't like we have no toilet and
you're like what star back to five years
yeah and they're like no no no we don't
even have one just I end up going to a
Ralph's yeah I've been there pretty
horrific yeah been there my girls
probably not the worst no no what are
bucks would have been worse I've been
doing really disgusting what well I've
been to wrong not I peed that you hover
you don't sit yeah really yeah do that
they hover I don't get the hover there's
special species and they've got a little
dangling on back I don't know I still
don't really understand the vagina after
all these years if they really knew the
extent to how disgusting we are all
right most of them we didn't watch those
game yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Brooke gross whoa I'm really excited to
uh I'm really excited to try that
because I am so / - like I'm such a baby
wipe fanatic that if
I have I have to [ __ ] and I'm sure it's
you have this probably worse with this
whole high-tech toilet okay when you
have to go without it it's just like how
do i its and the toilet paper it's so
it's an amazing bro
it's enraging it's like [ __ ]
sandpaper yeah when I you know if I'm
home for a while and then you go on the
road you're not even thinking about it
you're in a hotel and the first time
you're like oh no and you you feel like
you feel uncivilized what you're did I
just step into sitting here with just
regular [ __ ] Mearing [ __ ] yeah that's
all you're doing is like rubbing it all
in there you know and you know you can
never really get it clean with that
uh-uh
do you ever get [ __ ] marks on your
underwear with the bidet be honest I
can't thank you can't I'm saying I can't
think of of seeing one I also have no
white underwear yeah yeah none it's like
96% black everybody yeah never buy white
underwear machine be available for
Europe [ __ ] hairy fat guy you're
crazy
Jared probably is white underwear oh
yeah well now it's it's it's
state-mandated yeah yeah oh man well
okay we're gonna close it off okay I've
got one thing I love to ask you about we
do this with all of our guests okay we
ask at the bottom of all of our podcasts
it's just a little strange little funky
okay have you ever had a ghost
experience a UFO experience or any
paranormal experience and it's totally
fine if you're like you know what I
never have I never have yeah I I don't
really feel like I have I remember
cousins trying to trick me into thinking
like I remember a particular experience
where they were like they were dropping
red dye from the ceiling but I don't
feel like I've ever had a paranormal I
feel the exact same way here I've never
done a small thing but you know what you
never know I enjoyed like 90% of our
guests do have yeah still Jordan Peters
had these incredible ghost stories I was
like completely blown away really never
know to expect it's always in the sale
of how somebody presents it - right like
Jordans uh he's a story storyteller
knows how to knows how to speak it works
across yeah yeah
knows how to work it I mean these people
who are like I say ghosts okay all right
buddy thank you
so it's probably generally don't have
them on yeah really
criteria you know I mean I I never I
never have I I'm very skeptical of all
that stuff though yeah I kind of go and
do it like I don't buy any of it poor
people who have seen it are so convinced
they're condensed like I can't I can't
and these are people that I trust and
know mm-hmm and I can't be like you're
[ __ ] lying or crazy so it's hard to
it's hard to you know make the
difference between yeah being so
skeptical of it but then someone you
trust saying like I know I've seen it
goes mm-hmm yeah I mean I don't know I I
feel like being like you think you
thought I thought I said Santa when I
was seven you know in the sky like I
told people you know and you can also
like I remember telling you can make up
stories that you believe and take years
to realize that you definitely made it
up I remember when I lived in Minnesota
at Minnie as others in Minneapolis as a
kid for a few years and when we left
people would always ask me about how
cold Minneapolis is and I told them
about a teacher we were outside and it
got so cold that her ear fell off
it froze and actually broke and you know
people would just be baffled by this and
you know with every year and every time
you tell it more you just kind of like
it just becomes this thing and I
remember like ten years later I mean I
was late teens maybe in college even
telling it to somebody about and like
going into all the detail we're at this
playground and you're so girl and
somebody actually as I told that goes
that didn't happen what they're like you
definitely were making that up
and I just like took a beat and I was
like yeah like I I just totally I've
lied for that one guy yeah and this took
someone to be like that's not a true
story and I'll try that what's my next
guess you know because you know I think
somewhat some people would be like well
I felt like it was real but it's
somebody like instead of endorsing the
story and being like wow that's amazing
cuz if you get somebody with like minded
experience or wants to hear it that the
story grows yes but if you have the
person who's like yeah it could have
been a dog you know then they're like
huh I guess you're definitely worried
about that yeah yeah all right well hmm
that about does it
yeah I'm sorry that I have to run to
this no worries that was a action-packed
hour 30 that's a great podcast the time
went by it was well enjoyed Tom Segura
I'm a huge fan and I urge everybody
right now to head on over to Netflix
watch disgraceful mostly stories and
completely non I urge you to vote at
Thomas Accord comm t om s e-g you are a
yes sir that helps that helps why not
dot-com slash tort yeah if you guys want
to get tickets to his upcoming tour in
August and and of course the podcast
yeah which I'm not gonna mess up this
time your mom's house yes yes and we'd
love to have you guys on anytime yeah
yeah no that'd be fun to have you guys
on and we talked to other talk Browns at
your house right still at our house
where you know we're in the midst of
looking at studios but so before you
move let me get in there I can do the
review we can continue this conversation
bro now make sure you have a hardy one
in you before you come over well let's
have a cup of coffee
perfect yeah we do know when you when
you guys want we'll be there okay
perfect like we live near but yeah it'd
be excellent Tom thank you so much thank
you for having me guys guys I hope you
enjoyed next week we've got who do we
have next week boogie boogie awesome
that's gonna be awesome this and really
looking forward
that I want that teddy fresh swag we're
gonna hug right now when it's [ __ ]
it's a right or Wednesday Tuesday that's
right okay with Tuesday so guys god
bless you appreciate you love you and
will most definitely be seeing you next
time thanks for watching
[Music]
you